let me start with the science fiction
reference okay
few weeks ago i was watching a tv series
in apple tv called foundation it's a
it's based on a russian
sci-fi novel
the same name
and in that tv series the protagonist
terry sheldon was developing
mathematical models in a tablet computer
and you can see he's kind of
using a dynamic media to do mathematics
he's doing single manipulation and he's
kind of interacting with the dynamic
diagrams
and interacting with all the visual
elements there i'm putting a sketch
representation for copyright because for
copyright reasons i cannot show the
actual footage
so when i saw this clip
it reminded me of an article written
almost 50 years ago
that is
dinah book by alan k i mean in the 1970s
lmk envisioned that you know
competed as a powerful universal medium
where people of all ages can tinker
play
and learn with a part of dynamic media
you know today it sounds obvious but at
that time that was a radically different
perspective
now we have seen remarkable progress
along this line like many of this work
inspired my own research among many
others
but till today i feel like we haven't
realized that vision fully this is still
a science fiction like the apples
foundation
you know day-to-day life when you're
brainstorming when you're communicating
when you're ideating how many of us do
leverage the power of your interactive
and dynamic traffic fully power up
competition media we still rely
on you know static whiteboards and texts
and whatnot static representation
so what would it take to make dynamic
representations and diagrams ubiquitous
accessible and you know spontaneous
that's what i'd like to talk today i've
been working in this space for almost 10
years and i'd like to share my
perspective
the talking about representations let's
take a look at some of this
representation you know
written representations like text help
us to communicate idea visual
representations help us to see complex
patterns in data
and you know symbolic representations
like mathematics help us to identify
dimensions and abstractions
now it's important to remember that all
these representations we are familiar
with today and use in our day to day uh
works
they're all developed for hundreds of
years in a static media
for pen and paper
but you know with the power of computers
you know our representations can be
dynamic by fully leveraging the power of
interactivity animation and what you
know
and what not for instance you know they
could really augment our live
presentations and videos by
by augmenting with
you know interactive and live graphics
they can we can create you know
interactive visualizations in augmented
reality that are driven by you know
physical phenomena like pendulum
or you know using our gestures and you
know speech we can actually visually
represent our dynamic idea in a head we
can have a dynamic representation of our
dynamic idea so we kind of see the part
of dynamic media here but you know
creating dynamic graphics is hard
because we have to rely on very you know
complicated softwares programming and
and other tools
so
our goal is to make
interactive dynamic representation
spontaneous making them as fluid as
language and gestures and speech and
like just like talking just like having
a conversation
but there are there are a number of
challenges to do that
first of all the dynamic designing
dynamic tools that are easy to use it's
hard because you know we are so used to
static media right
and you know and to be honest designing
dynamic tools is also not accessible
like people need to know programming for
complicated softwares to create dynamic
representations
second we have to there's we have to
draw a balance between expressiveness
and fluidity and it's always hard right
we want to make things very simple easy
and fluid but at the same time we want
to have really powerful representations
to represent complex ideas
and finally dynamic representation
requires new interactions that means new
way of understanding people's mental
models new way of input output mappings
and all and human preferences
so let's talk about these challenges
today
so to give you a perspective i have been
working on dynamic blind for a while
dynamic drawings is a medium that
captures dynamic phenomena and ideas
with the power of you know animation and
interactivity as a matter of fact some
of these tools are available as
commercial products today
the goal of this tool is to make us to
make animation as easy as sketching you
know without the complex of timeline and
keyframing really leveraging the power
of direct manipulation and by example
phenomena to create animations in a
drawing tool not in an animation tool
just like you know creating things in
the speed of the thought
but
you know
as we explore that space we realized
that at some point we hit a ceiling of
explosiveness we saw that you know
when we want to portray more complex
ideas
we want to we have to move beyond direct
manipulation interfaces just in the
context of animation let me give you a
simple example look at this
animation right in this case the
animation is not going up and down but
this additional dynamics into this
animation that makes this thing so
expensive full of life right by the way
this this animation is uh you know is a
combination of two of my very favorite
films ratatouille from pixar and mad max
from uh another film just for reference
so we looked at how can we design
dynamic tools that can help us to bring
stylized dynamics into these dynamic
interfaces
uh again it's important to remember that
we are not developing animation tools we
are developing drawing tools that help
us to create dynamics
in a fast and fluid way
so
i will talk about several projects how
we design these tools
so first one is motion amplifiers which
talks of which actually is inspired by
the disney's 12 principles of animation
disney animators designed these
principles of animation to bring the you
know emission of life into their
drawings
and they guide the temporal and
geometric aspects of the animation so
before diving into the interface and the
interaction let's take a look at how an
animator thinks inside his or her head
right
what happens in their mind imagine you
want to recreate this animation right
how are you thinking about it how are
you constructing it in your head okay
you first add follow-through you know
to for the secondary motion and then you
kind of add staging to highlight the
animation that means that the motion
line and then you add slowing slow out
for the timing and then squash and
stretch
so once you combine all these effects
you get something like
the final final artifact
so that really shows how an animator is
constructing all these complex dynamics
into their headlight by combining simple
understandable principles
uh inspired by this insight we developed
an interface where in a drawing tool we
expose these principles as we call
motion amplifiers
so let's take a look at this interface
so imagine i have drawn as very
i've sketched a bird and with direct
manipulation i just recorded a simple
motor the bird is just moving up and
down not much not enough interesting
right so now you see the principles of
animation and explode export as filters
or motion amplifiers
i apply slow and slow out and you
immediately see the timing effects then
i apply a little bit of squash on the
stretch
and control how much squash and slit i
want more or less
and then i want to add a little bit of
dragging so i specify which part of the
body is primary and then you know which
part of the secondary and then you see
the effect immediately and finally to
highlight the motion
i add a little bit of
staging and then get an animation like
this
again
i will show another example where you
know i'm drawing a simple shark and
record a motion path right just direct
manipulation
and then
since i selected arc you see as the
object is moving it is deforming along
the arc
and then i apply slow and slow out and
you see
the temporal aspect are being applied to
it
and then i applied staging
for motion line and anticipation so that
the shot moves back before moving
forward
so again these are examples of dynamic
tools that helps us to add stylization
on top of our direct manipulation
interfaces
to really bring the illusion of life
into our drawings
so here is an example you know without
any
amplifiers this is how
the cloth animation would look like when
i just directly manipulate to record the
motion
and then if i apply two amplifiers this
is how it looks like
when i add dragon staging this is how it
looks like
you know one of the founding principles
in the design of this tool is that the
tools
should enable the conditions for
invention in famous paperwork you know
it's not providing ready-made knowledge
but you know
by using the tool the users are able to
learn these principles right it's it's
providing a
platform for experimentations for
instance you know this is how an apple
an animation look like when you apply
the four amplifiers secondary motions
going slow out squat and switch and drag
once you take out drag this is how it
looks like
and once you take two other amplifiers
this is how it looks like
so you see as a user i can learn
what each amplifier adds and take away
from the animations
as a result i have an intuitive
understanding what these principles are
and what do they do
and also the users by combining these
simple principles at will
in different ways they can create more
complex expressions than animation
effects
so that's the principles of these motion
amplifiers
a follow-up work led by jiajuma is
appearing to pi 2022 this is this is
pushing this work into 3d space but if
you're interested in this feel free to
take a look at this work
now uh
now we move into secondary animations
fire fluids you know hairs and things
like that
and you know second creating this kind
of secondary animations are really hard
because you know the physics based but
at the same time they're really hard to
control
so we took inspiration from the books
written in 1970s and 80s by joseph
gilland and you know joseph gillan is
very famous
animator in disney and he used to
draw all this special effect animation
in hand
so he really
he really explains in his book how they
use these energy lines to stylize the
animation effect an important aspect of
this animation is that
we want to stylize and exaggerate them
we do not want to just apply
physics-based animation and in computer
graphics this is a classic problem right
how do you
balance between you know physics and
simulation and stylization and controls
classic problem
so in the context of dynamic drawings we
want to
build just like motion amplifiers
simple atomic tools with which animators
can build with complex expressions
and now i'll talk about energy process
led by june xing that helps us to
achieve those type of effects so let's
take a look how the interface works
here is the
energy brush interface
so as you can see
i can draw this simple brush and it
actually emits these flow particles
along the brush
these flow particles are actually
essentially velocity films and each of
the flow particles have their own type
of velocity
so what we are creating is that we are
creating a repetitive velocity field now
if we put some drawing into the fill you
will see how they are being affected by
this velocity field
you see
now as you put more drawings
uh they are being animated but these
animations are repeatedly and you know
uh kind of boring but as a user you can
control you know the different
parameters like the size strength
interval speed etc to create different
types of expression
now let's see how this
energy brushes works in action
so in this case i will create a wave
animation i start with a very simple
repetitive pattern by drawing a single
brush and fine-tuning the parameters
but now
on top of it i will construct another
brush to add more dynamics
and more randomness
and just by adding two to three brushes
i have an animation like this so you see
complexity arises by composing this very
simple understandable energy brushes and
at the user head because you're
constructing them from simply from
scratch
you have a very intuitive understanding
about how these things work so energy
brushes are an example of another type
of dynamic tools but in the context of
secondary animation
so now important thing is you know these
are all
dynamic representations examples of
dynamic representations right but we
also enable users to develop their own
dynamic representations
own visualizations
in for instance in this case
a user is developing own custom build
flow particles right
flow particles that is changing over
time and because he's designing the
particle in a way so that the rapid
changes in the velocity field
you will see abduct changes in that into
the animation itself
and as a result we can create an
animation like this fire animation
and this kind of surprised us because we
didn't anticipate users to get effect
like this
here are some other animations creating
creating energy brushes
so again the overarching goal of this
you know dynamic tool is to build
academic tools
to break down complex tools into mind
size by this so that they are more
communicable assemble and contractable
complexity arises by composing these
simple understandable tools
so you know one of the first thing we
learn along this line is that
we really need to empower creators to
build their own representations and
dynamics
we can do that by building academic
tools and often that requires very
interdisciplinary research and deep
understanding about the domain
so we have shown tools like foreign
dynamic groups would look like in the
context of animation but think about
other domains like how dynamic tools
look like you know
let's say mathematics or explorable
explanations
or other domains of science arts and
research how they look like
an interesting problem to think about
now the second problem of dynamic
representations as i mentioned is the
tension between expressiveness and
fluidity right we want to
have research tools like you know silk
by james landay and you know case sketch
but at the same time we want to be able
to create really powerful
representations and you know
for instance like unity and other
programming tools that give us a lot of
free
expectedness and freedom but they're
very difficult to use
so
in this section i will briefly talk
about two projects that in my mind
achieves a nice nice balance by
leveraging different types of
representation in the operating process
visual representations and more symbolic
presentation
so the first work is called embodied
algebra led by nasmus
so overarching goal of this
project is to create pictorial
representation of mathematical
expressions in this case algebraic
expressions
so you know it is motivated by the fact
that you know in child
this is in the early childhood we start
mathematics by you know embodied
mathematics by being able to count
objects and then group them
add and subtract them picture based
mathematics but as we grow older in the
school we start doing simple
manipulation and eventually go go to
computer algebra system and algebraic
expressions
now throughout the way many students
lose the intuitive underpinnings and
understandable aspects of you know
embodied mathematics you know being able
to
concretely visualize what's happening
there
now
let's take a look at a very simple
example right we want we have a very
simple
algebraic expression we want to create a
pictorial dynamic pictorial
representation of this attack session
the example is that there are two houses
and two apartments and one house for
students and one for teachers
what is the total population very simple
problem right h1 plus h2 h1 is for
students h3 for kitties
so on the left is kind of the algebraic
expressions you know h1 plus ph2 h1 is
students h2 is teachers and on the right
side
is a pictorial representation of the
same expression
what we want to do is to combine these
two representations in a way so that we
can interactively and iteratively create
a dynamic representation using this
using the both of the
spectrum of the
representation
so here is how the interface looks like
right
in this case
the user is drawing
some students
and teachers
and then make copies of students and
teachers circles are students teachers
are squares
now in the second part we will create a
list a list will count how many students
and teachers are in that particular area
or polygon
so
list is essentially a set and we can
actually name the site a list has some
getable and settable properties for
instance you see the list has one or two
depending on you know how many elements
you put into it it outputs the number of
elements into that list
now we will create a list an apartment
you see a list is represented as a
window right so we create a window and
say you know in this apartment or window
there will be four five students each
so we create a list and you as you can
see it's a very pictorial representation
of a set and then put all the students
here and as you're putting the students
you'll see it kind of shows how many
students are in there in the list
similarly we create more copies of that
list and then we create a mega list that
will contain all this like apartments so
this is for the house and you will see
this house shows 20 as the total number
so the left one is for students and the
right one is for teachers
again
we'll create another house for the
teachers and you see the house is
another
maker list that shows the summation of
all the apartments
finally we will create a function brush
and in this case function also has a
pictorial representation in this case uh
scampers the green campus or road
and you know a function has many
properties like you can you can in this
by default you could say summation but
you can also specify multiplication and
there are other type of mathematical
properties and as we put these houses
into the function into this campus you
can see that that is being reflected
into the function output
you see here it is 15 but when we put
the other house here this is 35.
now we mostly talked about pictorial
representation but really the power of
this you know interface is to be able to
navigate up and down through the
different types of representation so
this is a hybrid representation that
shows there are four students inside the
students
and this is symbolic representation
where the variable win equals to four
that means there are four students
similarly for the house you can see
there are different levels of
abstraction visualization h1 is 20
and this is intermediate representation
and this is the picture representation
so for the entire expression this is the
pictorial representation
this is a
this is actually the intermediate
representation and finally
this is the mathematical representation
h1 plus h2
and we can see we can navigate up and
down these letters of abstraction so
once we have a dynamic representation
like this we can create stories for
instance we could say that you know
you could draw a bird
and say you know if the in the campus
when there are more people the birds
move away right you can just create a
simple expression like this we draw a
bird create a path
and then
create a relationship between the
function and the part so that you know
when the count is more the part will
move further away
so essentially what we have done in this
interface is that we have created a you
know
a dynamic representation pictorial
representation of algebraic expression
to create storytelling and narration and
that
that representation delivers different
types of representation so this is an
another example of exploration
explorable explanation
that shows
a transformer coil and how we calculate
voltage
as we add more calls into it
you see there are like ratio counted as
division and output concept as much
multiplication
here is another example created the
similar interface that shows
whether a specific area is busy or not
and as you can see there are different
types of function here
as if there are more elements more
subway into the function it drives the
rotation of this element whether it's
busy normal or otherwise
so by creating simple algebra expression
and giving them pictorial
representations we can tell stories
and also in students case bridge the gap
between you know abstract symbolic
representation
and more embodied representation of
mathematics
so the second example is rapido
this is another interface where we are
trying to create an interactive
representation of
an interactive experience of augmented
reality
you know
this work is led by hermann laba and
let's say this is the resulting artifact
we want to produce a very simple app
where you know we have a catalog and we
select the furniture from the catalog
and then we place it our environment
that's it that's the that's the idea i
have in mind
now i want to represent it
now if we were to use a static media we
would have used let's say storyboard or
written words to expressive idea right
but we want to see how can we represent
this idea
using a dynamic representation in a way
that others can experience it interact
with the contents
so let's see how can we do it
so again i always go details into the
interface there are many components in
the interface i will only talk about the
most relevant part of the stock
so there are three steps to do this
first of all video prototyping the
second one is the most relevant one
programming with examples and the third
one is testing
in the video prototyping stage we kind
of you know uh
record the whole
scene
using the ipad so this is just a video
recording
and once we have the video recording we
start
we start drawing different types of
elements
and then we just do a video editing we
record the input actions
and then specify like when and where
this each of the elements should appear
in the screen for instance in this case
i recorded a tab interaction
and then i manually do the video editing
to say when i do the tap interaction
this object will appear from this time
to this time in the timeline
so i encourage you to see more relevant
works in video prototyping it's an old
concept i won't go into the details but
this is more like a video editing and
the ultimate artifact is a video that
demonstrates how this interactive
product will work
now we have seen some words in this hand
but in this case we want to create an
interactive representation right that is
the goal of it so we need to do a little
bit more work
now
at this stage we just have a video to
show the idea
now in the final stage we introduce
additional types of representations
in this case for instance we introduce
when we move to the third stage it
brings a new representation the timeline
that shows what are the different states
of the inputs and outputs and what are
the different inputs and you know
and all these interaction mechanism are
represented with a state diagram on the
right side and a user can you know have
absolute creative control to you know
merge these states rename these states
and so on but what's interesting about
this step is that
because of this additional
representation the state diagram and the
timeline
we were able to create a dynamic
representations of the idea so that the
user can actually interact with the idea
now it's not just a video anymore anyone
can use the interface and create
interactive prototypes so
the reason these new types of abstract
representations like the state diagram
and timelines are very important is that
because
this gives us capabilities to express
ideas that would have been very
difficult using the video editor or you
know just visual and it had to introduce
this new representation to make it very
expressive
but without
without sacrificing the fluidity along
so this is the
final
final artifact
and at the end of the session
you get you have an interactive artifact
an interactive experience someone can
actually interact when you tap it an
object appears in the scene and then
when you double tap it the object is
being placed into that particular area
so
how do we balance
uh expressiveness and fluidity and as we
as we have seen in this two talk in
these two projects
one way to do it is to enable creators
to navigate through ladders of
abstraction
being able to create different types of
representations enable different types
of representations to express ideas and
this actually points to the potential of
multi-modal interfaces you know maybe
there's a plenty of opportunity to use
you know pen and gestures and speech
together to create dynamic
representations
the final one is new interactions right
how do we enable new interactions as we
have been exploring you know interfaces
for dynamic representations we ask
ourselves you know
what how these dynamic representations
look like in these new devices that are
coming up in here and vr or even you
know video presentations what do they
mean what is the interesting space what
kind of interactions are necessary
both in tablet as well as you know these
are vr experts
one of the work that really motivated us
is hands frosting video this is a video
where hence wrestling is explaining
the relationship between you know wealth
and lifespan
and as you can see in this case he's
using his whole body to interact with
the charts right as if like these
graphical elements are a natural
extension of his body and speech again
this is a well produced video by a
studio it's not real time it's not in
presentation it's like most like post
production
but it really opened our eyes to the
possibilities of using you know body
languages as a way to interact with
dynamic representations create analytic
presentations and so on
so fortunately we found a work that
explored the design space of you know
meteor hand gestures right uh eigener
did a user study that explored
how people
uh
use their gestures to access different
types of ideas and parameters to a
computer program
and it it kind of shows the range of
gesture languages people use from direct
manipulations to more like abstract and
iconic gestures and really opened our
eyes to the rich design space
so
our kai 2019 work interactive body
driven work explores how can we leverage
you know with which input
input expressions
to make our presentations more dynamic
so that our live video streaming like
the one i'm doing now can be augmented
with
uh you know interactive topics that are
given by our performance
essentially we developed a powerful tool
like presentations where you create
slides and you do simple mappings
between input gestures and output
graphics
and then when you are presenting the
slides in the previous slide this is how
the slides look like you know it's an
interactive artifact and this is another
example of a slide where you know
drawing two anchors between two hands
and uh and the red graphics
and this is how the slides look like
when you're performing you as you're
rotating the slide it's kind of changing
the timeline of the graph
and
this is the setup where you have we have
a kinect sensor and there's an augmented
reality in front of the presenter so
that drg can get immediate visual
feedback
now the most important thing about this
project is the mapping interface
we actually developed a mapping
interface where users can
define their own user interactions
when a musical performer does a gesture
like this it means something very
different compared to an educator
or a corporate presenter
everybody has a unique gesture language
and that's why we felt like
enabling users to map their own data
input and output was absolutely critical
for this
for this effect
and our goal was to come up with a
simple way to represent this mapping
enable them
enable this mapping please take a look
at the paper for more details
and here are some of the other
here are some of the presentations
again you can see these are all live
presentations
and the users are using their gestures
and body
this is a harvard student
actually presenting his research paper
on astrophysics
and presenting real data
and this is another user brainstorming
how to you know do the interior design
of our
of our apartment
and again you can see all the rich you
know input and output actions
another student another teacher talking
about how to deal with depression
and a youtube influencer
now we are talking about new
interactions and input output mapping
right but the challenge of this project
is that all these mappings were done
beforehand right
you have to prepare all this mapping
when you're preparing the slide and then
you just perform them and there's very
little room for improvisation
uh when you're doing the presentations
so you looked at okay how can we enable
mapping in real time you know and this
is very critical for explorable
explanations of teaching where we are
experimenting with ideas we want to
being able to create new visual
representation new dynamic
representations on the fly
consider a scenario like this right
where someone is trying to teach us
how what kind of um
motion that pendulum gets it creates a
simple harmonic motion uh oscillation
right
but we want to create that visual
representation in real time when i'm
experimenting with the pendulum
so our follow-up work explores how to do
these mappings or how to design this
interaction in real time
so here is uh
how the system works really this sketch
led by real surgery
so let me show how the interaction works
in this case a teacher is
showing how what kind of and
what kind of emotion that a
pendulum creates
so an assistant is creating this
annotation that like like the lines
and then
he actually names the angle right this
is angle and he creates the charge and
maps the angle and now you will see the
angle being visualized in real time
so this is using apple air kit of course
and here are some other visualizations
being created in real time this is for
light experiments this is for explorable
explanations in mathematics this is for
tangible interfaces and i will show one
more example about how this interface
works and this is for this is for you
know physics educations
so another example how it works right in
this case the teacher is trying to teach
the concept of reflection right so we
select the object
we actually select the solid color
object
and then i draw a line
sketch on the screen and this creates a
line and you can see the length of the
line and then now i will create an angle
and you will see the angle is changed i
will create another angle but you know
that those angles are independent from
each other but in reflection the angle
should be the same so we named the same
angle and now they are binding together
and you can see how reflection works
and we kind of show the application of
this real-time mapping how they could be
useful in many applications like in
teaching
and you know augmenting physics
experiments
explorable explanations
where we are actually comparing the
movement between the two angles so they
have an understanding how the size
affects the angle
the radius of the will affects the angle
so as a student just like you know
embodied mathematics it helps us to base
different types of representations right
our experience with the everyday world
physical objects to more abstract
representations like diagrams and you
know mathematical expressions and so on
and the interface further shows its
application in you know sports and
applications and in situ tangible
interfaces again
the important thing is that all the
interactions are designed and created in
real time the mappings are done in real
time
in improvisational ways
so overall i mean i'm really excited by
the possibilities of you know uh
spatial interfaces like air and gear
interfaces how we'll be able to you know
represent our dynamic ideas with you
know gestures and speech and other types
of modalities plenty of exciting work to
be done in that space
so
as you have seen you know one of the
most important thing for new interaction
is that we need to empower users and
creators to define their own
parameterization and mapping
and we found that you know that is
critical
that is very critical for expressiveness
and that is very critical to design
enable users to use this type of
capabilities and variety of application
domains
so dynamic representations can really
enhance the way we communicate
and id8
for using by leveraging the part of
computational media
you know think about this example in
1948 a richard femen who is over the
nobel laureate developed feminine
diagrams
which are actually a pictorial
representations of mathematics
describing the behavior of subatomic
particles
and it revolutionized the every aspect
of theoretical physics
i wonder like if richard clement was
alive today and if he were to develop
this new representation today in a
computational medium let's say he knew
programming
how this representations look like you
know
using the power of you know animation
and interactivity different types of
ladders of abstraction different types
of mapping
you know
in 20 years 50 years or 100 years we
don't know what the new front case of
science and technology will be but
whatever it is new representations if
they will play a significant role in
advancing and our intellectual and
communication communication capabilities
and
as a researcher it's a researcher it is
our responsibility to facilitate that
progress by really empowering users
to build new dynamic representations
navigate different ladders of
abstractions and of course facilitate
new types of parameterizations and
mapping for new interactions
so all these works are
done in collaboration with excellent
students and collaborators without whom
this work is not actually possible
and with that
i'd love to take questions from you
thank you
cool thank you for the fantastic talk um
now we are opening up the floor to
questions um if you're in the room in
the auditorium please raise your hand if
you're on a zoom you can also press the
right hand button
okay
um so while we're waiting uh for
questions to trickle in i i do have a
question um
so uh this this is really great work and
very very exciting um
have you considered um
[Music]
maybe uh have you considered dynamic
representations um in the audio space
um
what kind of like atomic um
uh like atomic tools do you think are uh
what makes sense
that's a good question
i haven't and as i mentioned earlier i
think that's why it is very important to
have very interdisciplinary research
like
to develop those atomic representations
we need to work with you know audio
folks who have deep deep knowledge and
different deep knowledge about that
space
so the short answer here is i i think
there's a lot of potential but i don't
know because i'm not an audio expert
okay we have a
question
hi i'm curious if you have a working
definition of dynamics
by dynamics i mean mostly interactive
and animated but of course you know it's
up for
up for interpretation
but to me that's what dynamic means
it could be it could mean more things to
many people that means that you know
being able to maybe get different
representations being able to bridge the
gap between different representations
and whatnot but i think
interactivity and motion captures all
those aspects of dynamics
so so would um
like a keyframe animation
uh application
creates something dynamic in your
definition
potentially yes
yes
but the problem with uh keyframe
animations so that you know it's not
it's not spontaneous it takes time to
create this type of representation but
yes i think keyframe animation is an
example of dynamics
cool
awesome
um i i have another question um so for
uh the first project that you uh
presented
um it was really cool how
um
you broke down the uh animations into
these atomic uh
uh animations which you can then later
compose together how did you decide on
those uh particular animations um
yeah yeah yeah again those though those
insights we got those inside tips from
you know classic animation literature
written in the 70s even before computer
animation tools came in so i i i can say
that those
those atomic representations were
inspired by the twelve principles of
animation written down by you know early
dc animators
and that's how they used to think in
their mind those are not completed tools
but you know those are more like mental
tools that's how they explain okay i
think your animation needs more
anticipation or i think you should add a
little bit of squash and stretch
basically that is the language they use
to communicate with each other and we
like just try to leverage them leverage
that language that said
the 12 principles of animations were
developed by these neonatals is very
personalized that's not universal
maybe the japanese or asian animators
have developed their own language right
maybe they will have a different set of
atomic tools
so i think that's why it's important to
enable other creators to develop their
not just complex expressions but develop
their own attributes
um we have another question um hi there
um so i was wondering because you had uh
examples of
um these dynamic representations being
used in like physics education both kind
of in a more
like um
text and and images based space and also
in the sort of real life space and i was
wondering if there's any if there's been
any discussion of um
using something like uh natural language
processing to
get from text
or to get from spoken language uh maybe
a sense of what of the sort of basic
tools
might be most appropriate in a certain
scenario and maybe help guide the user
um
make those tools more easily accessible
to the user in
the moment based on like a text or or
speech
yeah josh thank you very much question
and that is an excellent question i
believe that you know the natural
language processing has in the future as
a
big role to play to create this type of
interaction and you know currently
actually we are exploring some of those
nfc based interactions to live to work
with other modalities like sketch and
speech so i think
as i mentioned in the second part you
know how to draw a balance between
expressiveness and fluidity and we
talked about you know the importance of
having different types of presentations
right when we are sketching we are also
talking right so
uh
definitely
it points that there's a lot of room for
opportunities and new interaction
techniques for multimodal interactions
and text and speech
interaction is one of them
and it is an area of our active research
interest i'd like i'm happy to chat more
with you about it
would dynamic representation unlock the
possibility of better representations of
emotions and feelings
yeah that's an excellent question i i
believe that in a way the emojis or you
know animated emojis and messenger are
an example of animated reference even
though they are not interactive i i i i
think they can go further but in a way
their example they're an example of uh
you know
emotions and feelings and actually i
have read a paper few weeks ago or like
last year
that in third world countries illiterate
people who are not being able to type in
messengers they communicate each other
fully with emojis that is their way of
communicating with the services like
purely visual media
so again i think there needs to be more
studies there might be more studies
there i'm not aware of but very
interesting space
for the look for the look at that space
in a way if you look at you know slack
or you know emoji space they are
changing how we express our emotions
right slightly more use and everything
thank you
um
so i i do have another question
um so for your project on the uh vector
field the vector field animation
i thought that was very cool
i was wondering um in the studies the
user studies that you've conducted with
with
animators and creators uh did they um
aim to like what types of animations did
they aim to create did they try to
create
um
like phys physically
uh
correct animations or did you find that
um they did not really care about that
aspect and was more
uh interested in the artistic
uh aspect
yeah it's a good question i think this
tool was built more for artistic freedom
not for physics-based animation
so it the tool was built for
dynamics designing dynamics but not
necessarily physics based
so in our user study users mostly
focused on secondary animations like
animating cloth and hairs
and you know or even octopuses
and things like that but what we found
is that
even with this tool people at some point
when you're building this complex
experience complex animation you have
many brushes it's hard to control at
some point you lose control you don't
know like how to get the desired effect
you have a desired effect in mind and
achieving that is still might be still
might still be
challenging so i would say
there is still room for improvement
about you know how to provide more
controllability without satisfying the
dynamic aspect of that process
you see
cool
um and also have you uh
considered um
like
doing dynamic representations also in
the vr space as well um
in addition to like ar and
uh
yeah yes yes of course i think i think
the the type of dynamic representations
we have discussed today they are all
applicable to both 2d and 3d so
whatever we have seen in 2d are also
applicable to vr as well so
this is an active area of interest i
would say but i think their definition
remains the same it's just like
the hardware is different but the
concepts are same
cool
um
any final questions
okay
cool um well thank you so much uh
robayette
this was a fantastic talk thank you for
your time
um thank you everyone for coming
if you have any more follow-up questions
later please feel free to email rubaiyet
and with that
thank you and have a great day everybody
thank you everyone bye